[Music]
you need a doctor
i am a
doctor should have died years ago
people all over the world have my
disease i'm here
to find a cure
we have to push the boundaries take the
risks
[Music]
if you're gonna run
do it now
dr michael morbius you've been missing
for two months when you're a stranger
then you were found on a container ship
that washed up off a long island
when you're alone
what did you do to yourself doctor
i wish i knew
i went from dying to being more alive
than ever it worked
not exactly i have increased strength
and speed
and some form of bad radar
what else can i do
[Music]
there are limits there has to be there's
something inside of me
[Music]
half the city wants to kill you
we haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco
the other half wants to control you hey
dr mike you and i should stay in touch
i'd do anything to save a life
but i don't know what i'm capable of
you save lives you don't take them
are you here to heal the world
or to destroy it
who the hell are you mad i
am i know
i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morvious at your services
recorders are on t-minus five
four
three
two
one
zero
[Applause]
there's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
and
july 20th 1969.
[Music]
in school you were taught that apollo 11
lost contact with the world for two
minutes
[Music]
not true
they found something on that day
that they kept him for 50 years
and now
it's too late to stop
in breaking news the governor has just
ordered the mass evacuation of the
entire west coast
moving to higher ground it's the only
possible chance of surviving
stay away my brothers and sisters
stay awake
this planet
has suffered five extinctions
this
is going to be the sixth
oh he dead
you know we are just inside the moon
that might be the greatest sentence
anyone's ever said
[Music]
[Music]
hello
what's your name
what the hell happened here
the umbrella corporation's been
experimenting on this town since we were
kids
people are getting sick
we have to stop umbrella show me your
hands
the world needs to know what's really
going on
get
out of this town
resident evil welcome to raccoon city
rated r exclusively in movie theaters
november 24th
got something
looks like we lost him
dr aldeway you have a patient who goes
by the name of dylan forrester he's one
of my most interesting most promising
patients
when was the last time you spoke has you
done something then you mean attempted
murder then yeah well that's progress
is there anything you need to tell me
no you're not the same man you used to
be deep dee's younger brother professor
sean forrester is dead the funeral is
today you got a lot of nerve coming here
get me someone in the washington state
police
the fbi he broke his ball short of him
move
you know the routine
i didn't expect to be here so soon
[Music]
you can't be the fbi not exactly we
search your house first and find out no
one dies until we find out what they
know trying to do my best here
don't be too hard on yourself
oh sure and i'll shoot you both
but now do you understand what happens
when you don't help me jacob
find your way back in
what aren't you telling me
sean must have told you what's here on
the island
you're being shot at
oh yeah
do whatever it takes to save your enemy
did you really kill people uncle bees
they were really bad people
i'm trapped here day after endless day
with my one maniacal
nemesis
four complaints this week four this is a
period when you take a period and put it
put that donut hole away or i'm gonna
shove it up
you two are the worst part of my job
we're gonna be hiring a managing
director we'll oversee each department
the job is mine shortcake if you get the
job i'll resign just like you will if i
do ah but i'm incapable of giving you
that pleasure well it's not the first
time you've said that to a woman is it
are you and he like there's eye there no
i hate him with a passion
wowzers what's the occasion
psychological warfare i wonder what it's
like to be using raw animal magnetism as
a weapon i had some weird dreams last
night i was in bed naked
i have a theory
what are we doing this game that we play
every day hating someone feels
disturbingly like falling in love with
them
let's play a different game a starting
over game why i don't want to be some
experiment before you settle down
[Music]
we are competing for the same job it is
impossible to trust each other i'm in
this you can trust that
i told you she'd back off if you let her
think that you could pet the pony
i don't need any help beating her
you would just do whatever it takes to
win whatever this is i don't want to do
it anymore
i don't understand you i thought you
hated me
so what game should we play now
lucy when you first met josh what did
you think i thought he was cold and
freakishly uptight i thought lucy was a
spineless kiss-ass it was hate at first
sight
it was a name that sounded so sweet so
seductive god meet the family everybody
this is patricia and this is my family
they had it all
worth style
power who wouldn't care for that
[Music]
ah but it's you my nephew i have been a
gucci all my life
it is an empire
you can help the family which is not
exciting and everybody knows it at least
it's my name sweetie
our name
sweetie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is not a woman's game
remember that
madness who does he think he is
it's time to take out the trash
gucci is a rare animal
he must be protected protected from home
from whoever threatens it
what game are you playing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't
miss
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't consider myself a particularly
ethical person no but i am fair
[Music]
i subscribe to
unconventional punishments
[Music]
it is time for a gentleman
and to
become rogues
let's go
you have no idea what i'm capable of
you're going to need a suit i might need
a shooting jacket
armed
and ready
i never drink on duty
we are the first spy organization
kingsman is it
and lady
theaters december 22nd
i have climbed
the highest mountains
i have run
through the fields
only to be
with you
only to be with you
but i still
haven't found
what i'm looking for
but i
still haven't found
what i'm looking for
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dream big trees
we just gotta be brave now wrong again
again
you will never be great johnny
what i'm looking for
[Applause]
what i'm looking for
swear your oath moraine to die
i swear to speak no word that is not
true
to make no weapon with which one person
may kill another
and never to use the one power as a
weapon
do you know what i said means in the old
town
servants of all
[Music]
it is they who serve the world
i didn't choose this path but i will
follow it
where next the two rivers the old blood
runs deep in those mountains
let's hope it's prepared then for what's
coming
the dark one is waking
but there will be one who can stand
against him
and it's one of the five of you
you fully lost your mind
your life isn't going to be what you
thought
what are those
his army is coming
what can we do
we protect the people we love
no matter the cost
our enemies are everywhere
they will leave no one standing
we've lost too many people already back
home
you
won't if we do not stop the dark one now
the whole world will burn
i can't allow it
the wheel weaves as the wheel wills
do you think we'll ever go back
home
no
you've been gifted this beautiful house
well you live here
can you believe it
[Music]
they've wanted to keep the place in your
family jamie
we really appreciate the house
well then you know
[Music]
it's got a hole in the roof the wheels
they'll do a good job jamie
you just carry on with your day as if we
weren't here
there is one thing i need to show you
and it's a little bit peculiar
every evening before sunset she'd leave
a blood offering here sorry did you say
blood
for who
for the red caps
[Music]
they'll need feeding
you'll be hungry
can i get in my own house please you
want own idea how many times have the
english come to this country and tell us
what areas is now theirs
they need to know their place
what did you leave out tonight oh shoot
you can't miss a single day
hello
is anyone there
i can't be scared i'm not in my own
house
don't leave your wrists alone with the
lads we feed it
every day
every day
every day
we just came here for some
[Music]
peace what's up with the picture
that
is a 70-75 bmw csl
thing of beauty say you're back 135k
i'm saving up
gonna get one how's that going for you
considering you just got fired had a
couple g saved
only another 133 000 to go
[Music]
i know a guy
nath clark hymn is curved on about 14
stick ups he's slick
he's the fourth man
collection
never done a robbery before
if you don't know why you're doing this
then you need to get out the car robbing
a bank
you know that's mad right 400 k yeah
because it's a police bank
what is he talking about i'm doing this
job it's suicide just think about it man
use your head
i'm in
can i trust you
four things you need for the artists
still
set up where you gonna hit him when
swell mob two to four no more
guns load of the blanks doesn't matter
people see guns they automatically think
death the getaway car ain't album
messing around messing around either
going to the big house
[Music]
he's playing in the bank goes wrong
you're probably gonna have to kill
somebody to get out
security guard woman
maybe even a kid
are you 12 i'm 16. don't flinch
you are surrounded junior you shot him
they're trying to keep him alive right
now if he dies i'm gonna kill him
do you really want to kill a little girl
is that why you came here today
man all i really want is to buy a 70 to
75 bmw csl 3.0 and drive away from here
forever well god damn
[Music]
hello please call me lauren
didn't you fight in the war that was
long ago
there's the next house you get in you
get the stuff i tell you to and you get
out i'll bring my garage this time
[Music]
hey there buddy
now why are you running
there's only one person who could have
done this
it's the gardener
gardener
he's a killer and so are all of you
they've seen my face they all died
what are you gonna do
save your family
if you want something done properly
do it yourself
so gardening have you always enjoyed it
yes
dear luca life in puerto roco is awesome
everything's perfect
especially my new job
i'm kind of the greatest fisherman in
the entire world
besides massimo of course
we're like pasta and pesto i'm gonna be
the perfect airplane
and i'll make massimo proud
i think he'll come around
ciao
[Music]
[Applause]
you want to come over and have a drink
[Applause]
[Music]
we got the house rules on the board over
here it's best two out of three to keep
the action moving okay
stay safe out there looks like you're
fixing a run no you got me alright
that's a blockbuster card
i don't like getting hustled
and things that i don't like wind up in
a hole in the [ __ ] desert i'm out
here
you know i've been trying to track her
down for over a year she's important to
me man
see you're still playing music yeah yeah
still banging away you know it's been
really good to me okay that's amazing
you gotta take care of here
[Music]
you are so
talented it's always just a matter you
put together
once again you have no idea what you are
talking about
[Music]
[Music]
let nobody out
[Music]
it's gonna be great it'll be just like
old dinosaurs that's scary
[Music]
[Music]
what's this
it's a journal so you can write to your
son
what do i write
tell him who you are what you believe in
and tell them you love them
[Music]
dear jordan
the moment i met your mother i knew she
was the one he is not exactly my title
[Music]
and after some convincing she fell for
me too
i think you are
[Music]
but i want to see more of beautiful city
i want to see more of your city i'll
take your state your zip code
[Music]
real love takes sacrifice
[Music]
we can make this work
[Music]
then you came into our lives
and you were a blessing
how come you barely ever talk about him
i think about him all the time
always be courageous in everything you
do
but never be afraid to cry
[Music]
i
will try i pray i don't run out of time
i love you to fix you
i was just thinking that if you need sex
just to help you get through it
then i don't want another woman and i
hope you don't expect me to extend that
same offer because you better keep that
locked up
exclusively in movie theaters this
christmas
ronald whitlock i'm not sure if you
heard but there's been an incident
my son
cops killed him it's a bit more
complicated than that it's crystal clear
to me
i did not think i'd see your ass in work
today we come from tougher park than
that weren't you like ex-military or
something yeah
you're a fugitive you killed two cops
i got a bone to pick
for my son
[Music]
if things don't go to my satisfaction
i'll flood this whole place
we're all gonna drown
[Music]
sorry dude you got a town to save
there's a rogue hostage
with some sort of military background
find him
[Music]
i gotta figure out a way to stop this
fool
they got guns
you got a goddamn gun
i got bear guns
open another gate
they're gonna flood the entire county
that is beautiful
[Music]
this is my legacy
you're crazy man you should try a little
bit of
crazy
hello uh
[Music]